what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the greatest Joker story
ever told the ending of this is gonna be
crazy right the end of this story is
going to be absolutely nuts and you're
going to see why it's the greatest Joker
Story Ever Told but this story takes
place during Flashpoint so for those of
you guys who have seen our videos when
we originally covered them or who have
recently watched the flashpoint full
story video that we recently uploaded
bear with me here because I think we
might be getting some people who are new
to all this so to give you guys a really
quick and dirty explanation about the
flash storyline this was basically a
story where Barry Allen The Flash had
gone back in time and saved his mom's
life but when he did that it is
basically altered reality we didn't
initially know he had done that we
didn't figure out that was the case
until later on down the line when
reverse flash throwed up but by changing
this whole reality here it was basically
a story where everything was turned on
its head this Batman story is very much
a part of that and it's the same way but
it's the reason why what you're going to
see over the course of this is that
there's going to be moments when Batman
talks about having the ability to change
history to change ways the way things
are supposed to be because he had
already met with Barry Allen and Barry
Allen had already told him what it was
that he had done and Barry Allen
intended to fix everything so he could
set the timeline back so that's what
Batman's basically talking about here
but what this does is it basically picks
up with Batman just essentially sitting
down and talking to a therapist now this
is an overly important in fact he
basically runs a whole like Wayne
gambling casino and everything that's
going on now I know this seems like a
little strange right why would Batman
running be running like a casino
operation all that kind of stuff this
all makes sense at the end so don't
worry I'm not gonna leave you guys
hanging it all makes sense at the end so
what happens here is of course him
meeting with this guy Batman's older
he's grizzled right he's a guy he looks
like he's from like the Batman Beyond TV
show right like just an old version of
Batman but he kind of talks about how
the whole reason why he's is even
meeting with this therapist is because
he has to verify that he's insurable
that he's of like sound mental health
and all that kind of stuff but all in
all like they know it's just a great big
huge sham and so ultimately the
therapist just stamps past on his file
and then of course all that stuff's over
but following this he meets with Oswald
cobblepot now this is one of the big
differences here in the main DC Universe
Oswald cobblepot is the Penguin he's a
bad guy right he literally runs a whole
nightclub that basically allows crime
and everything to operate through it
he's one of the many crime bosses that
exist in DC Comics unlike the Joker
who's just a madman and to really quote
the late great Kevin Conroy from Batman
the Animated Series that his schemes
make sense to no one but himself Oswald
cobblepod and even guys like Two-Face to
a degree they're more organized and
they're more structured so they have to
have a desire to kind of control their
segment of crime within Gotham City it's
not that way here right in this universe
penguin is basically just one of the
many guys who works for Batman and while
there is some erroneous stuff going on
here and even Batman himself is kind of
dabbling in crime too a to a degree what
he says is the reason why he has this
entire gambling operation and casino
operation going on in the first place is
because what it does is it allows crime
to come to him as opposed to him having
to go out and find crime it's a pretty
ingenious scheme to be honest with you
like it's pretty intelligent but
following that you basically have Batman
meeting with Commissioner Gordon now the
funny thing about this is of course he
kind of blows off Commissioner Gordon to
a degree so the relationship between the
two is a bit strained but there's a
really really interesting situation here
so of course much like the main DC
Universe Harvey Dent is the mayor of
Gotham City and so as they're having
this conversation one of the things he
says is he says Harvey's right right his
panties are in a bunch and the response
to Jim Gordon is his Twins were
kidnapped by The Joker does that qualify
for getting your panties in a bunch and
that's where Batman responds and saying
Jim there's nothing we can do about it
yet and of course the response to Jim is
try to tell him that and so then they
get into this discussion about Arkham
right and ultimately Batman just says
like Arkham's useless and that's where
the conversation picks up with Harvey
Dent and the question Harvey did has is
then why does the Joker always end up
there and the response of Gordon is
because he's insane and this is when
things get cool because Harvey didn't
responds and saying and a menace like
hush Scarecrow Poison Ivy and they're
all dead now one of the things about
this is that in this reality that you
instead of having a traditional police
force you've got Gotham security so
think of like Gotham police with that
are more like militarized that have more
of a military-like presence and that's
really what Gotham security is but the
other part of this is they say that
really Jim Gordon says like Gotham
security had no part in the death of
those different characters and that's
when the response of Harvey Dent is I
know Batman did and of course that's
when he points to Batman so one of the
things to know is I I doubt it's done on
a national level or on even like a
city-wide level but people who would not
traditionally know who Batman is know
who Batman is and that's kind of a funny
thing because the response of Harvey
Dent is you sold me on this idea that
like Gotham security could be a police
force that could be privatized and could
effectively keep the city safe and
instead now what we have is Batman who's
kind of picking up the slack but he's
killing villains now one of the things
to know here is that while Harvey Dent
quote unquote stands against this or
seems to stand against it in a lot of
ways he doesn't because one of the big
philosophical arguments that goes on in
the Batman comics is is Batman actually
doing the city of Gotham any good by
capturing villains like the Joker and
throwing him in an insane asylum knowing
that the system can't hold the Joker
that by whatever Manner and whatever
means the Joker will ultimately escape
and go back on a crusade in killing
people again isn't it better to simply
just kill those guys are there some
criminals that are just beyond
Redemption now I'm not arguing one way
or the other but what I am saying here
is there is a moral argument to be made
there right do the ends justify the
means basically utilitarianism if you
want to go that way but of course this
is what Harvey's wife kind of steps in
and she's mourning the whole process and
says like my kind of my my babies are in
the hands of a like a kid killer right
like that's what the Joker is here in
this universe and so that's where things
get kind of wild is because this really
impacts Batman on a very personal level
and we'll find out why right but it
really impacts him on a very very
personal level and even with Harvey Dent
it's the same way and so that's why when
you have Batman who stands up and says I
will get your kids back Harvey don't
worry the response of Harvey is you
better because if you don't I will
destroy everything that you have right
your your whole gambling casino
everything that Wayne's built on your
money the whole nine yards it's all gone
everything that you have is gone so in a
lot of ways what it looks like here is
Batman is basically a city sanctioned
vigilante and that's another major
difference from the main DC Universe
that in a lot of ways the city tolerates
Batman but they don't like Batman I mean
the average person does sure but like
the Gotham City Police Department
government officials they don't like
Batman they realize that he serves a
purpose and that he can kind of get
things done in a way that they can't but
they tolerate his presence at the very
best here he's almost kind of supported
and it's almost like yes we allow you to
do your thing because without you here
things will be much much worse but
understand we keep you on a leash to a
degree and so that's where things get
cool because this is one of those
moments when I talk about how Batman has
already met with Barry Allen during the
main Flashpoint Story the idea of
changing things up because he asked Jim
Gordon he says like the world's a bad
place like this world is a really bad
place because one of the things to know
and to understand what's going on
outside of Gotham in the flashpoint
Universe the Amazons and the atlanteans
are at war with each other Wonder Woman
and Aquaman they're at War right like
literally it's a world war between them
and there's like all kinds of people who
are caught in the side a lot of you guys
are probably asking where's Superman
during Flashpoint Superman's being held
by the government underground exposed to
a red Sun he's got a really really cool
story in Flash one it's really really
interesting and I'm pretty sure there's
a story that focuses on what happened
with Superman when he arrived in Flash
point I'll double check because if there
is we will definitely cover it because
it's one of the coolest things he's not
the Superman you know and honestly it's
one of the coolest stories about his
character but he talks to Jim Gordon and
says like if you could change things
right if you could change the world
would you and where Jim Gordon is kind
of responding by saying like that's what
I signed up for they're talking about
things from two different perspectives
Jim Gordon is talking about this from
like yeah I'm trying to change the world
by cleaning up crime and so on and so
forth but the reality is they both know
it's a stopgap measure right like for
every criminal that gets put away in
Gotham City another criminal is going to
take their place for a variety of
reasons right so it's a war of attrition
there's always one step forward one step
back there really is no progress being
made here but again what Batman's
talking about is after his meeting with
Barry and realizing that what's actually
going on here is Barry can change
reality then Batman's talking about on a
grander scale if you could literally
change the timeline would you do it and
so that's where things get really really
cool is because following this we of
course basically pick up with Batman
kind of continuing down into what passes
for the bat cave right it's not really
the bat cave like you know it doesn't
have like all these crazy Advanced super
computers and everything it's pretty
makeshift right it's it's it's it's like
what you would see in a setup video on
YouTube you know what I mean you got
like a Mac over there right and like a
couple monitors you know and like a
filing cabinet like that's literally it
it's not like the grandiose bat cave
right that we're all familiar with so
it's cool it's like a setup you and I
would have but again the other part of
this is that where Batman's asking Jim
Gordon what information they have in
relation to like the Joker that the
response of Jim Gordon is like we don't
really have anything concrete all we
have are just kind of the ramblings of
of junkies and and vagrants and people
whose word we may not necessarily
believe and even then they all just kind
of seem to be babbling nonsense they
keep talking about how like the devil
came out of the ground and snatched
people up and took them down to Hell and
we don't really know what any of that
stuff is but ultimately this leads to
Batman realizing there's more truth to
this than Commissioner Gordon is giving
it it's just clouded by a combination of
schizophrenia and being adult on drugs
and so once he gets down into the sewers
below Gotham he literally starts finding
body parts and then there's all these
people who are just kind of kept inside
this bunker who are literally begging
for help because they're essentially
being consumed right they're literally
just being like horse in doubt like legs
are missed seeing and hands are missing
and things like that they're being used
as food only for us to find out it's
actually Killer Croc now that's one of
the crazy things about this is because
again unlike the DC Universe where
Killer Croc does have a pretty dark
history and depending on what story you
read this is fairly normal in the
regular Batman comics Killer Croc isn't
necessarily like this he's a villain and
there's allusions to the fact that like
he eats people and in some Origins you
find out he does but to see him on such
a dark level where he's literally just
harvesting human beings who are alive by
removing body parts and eating them it's
pretty dark and it's pretty Twisted but
this is one of the other big differences
between Batman from the main DC Universe
and Batman and the story because of the
main DC Universe Batman would just like
beat this guy up right he would subdue
him and then he would hand him over to
Arkham and that's effectively it a fight
breaks out between the two and then
Batman literally gouges his eye out of
his head and then basically kills him
and so it's like okay like Batman's just
straight up killing folks literally
takes this machete and just gashes it in
the Killer Croc's head and that's the
end of him and then he cuts him in half
and so it's it's pretty messed up right
it's pretty Twisted but that's when we
switch over to the Joker and the Joker
basically possessing or having these two
twins of Harvey Dent just kind of starts
doing Joker Muses right just kind of
babbling to the to itself and the
Joker's saying things like you know
let's play house since there's three of
us someone gets to be the daddy and
someone gets to be the baby and the
mommy will all have fun and then he'll
show up right so it's just the Joker
kind of being the Joker to a degree but
following that Commissioner Gordon again
kind of launching his own investigation
aside from Batman trying to figure out
what's going on with like Harvey Dent's
kids basically says he's gonna go see
Oracle now in the main DC Universe
Oracle is Barbara Gordon the daughter of
Commissioner Gordon that she was Batgirl
when she first showed up and then during
The Killing Joke storyline she was shot
through the abdomen she was paralyzed
and because she was wheelchair bound she
couldn't run around the city of Gotham
she basically made up for it by being an
information broker she was the eyes and
ears of not just just about family but
even Commissioner Gordon himself and
depending on what fans you're talking to
there are a lot of fans out there and
I'm one of them I kind of like Barbara
Gordon Moore when she was Oracle than
when she was Batgirl but I think she was
just more interesting there was a lot
more going on with her character but in
this universe it's not Barbara Gordon
because Jim never had kids it's Selena
Kyle now the origin and what goes on
with Catwoman here isn't actually
explained in this story so we'll explain
it here the way this played out and this
was actually done during the city of
Bane storyline during Tom King's Batman
run that what we ended up finding out is
that because there was no Barbara Gordon
because Jim Gordon never had a daughter
instead Selena Kyle was her origin is
very much intact right she was kind of a
thief in her younger years almost a
prodigy when it came to being a burglar
but she was ultimately discovered by
Batman who took her under his wing and
then turned her into a robin right she
was literally just his sidekick now one
of the cool things about this happening
is that much like Dick Grayson when he
was originally made Robin in the old
Batman comics back in the 1940s in a lot
of way days it softened Batman here
because he was Hardcore and he had no
qualms with just killing criminals no
qualms with that but by having Selena
Kyle she provided a kind of gentler hand
but much like The Killing Joke storyline
when Barbara Gordon was shot Selena Kyle
was shot as well the difference is that
where Barbara Gordon was paralyzed from
the waist down like Selena Kyle is a
complete quadriplegic she does not have
the ability to move her arms or her legs
or really like any part of her body from
the neck down and so because of that she
is still sort of the information broker
but it's interesting to see that it's
Selena Kyle instead of Barbara Gordon
now for those of you guys who were
reading Tom King's Batman and you saw a
Flashpoint Batman show up in that story
this is the reason why he's so adamant
about ending the relationship between
Bruce and Catwoman because in his
Universe this is what happens to Selena
that her being by Batman's side in any
capacity will ultimately lead her to
meeting either death or potentially a
fate worse than death depending on who
you talk to so that's one of the big
reasons why he wanted to see that end
but it's a very sad moment here because
she really kind of talks about the idea
of the Joker and saying that like the
Joker goes after kids Selena Kyle was
one of his victims and she's always been
this way ever since she first
encountered The Joker and so again it's
a pretty dark and twisted moment but one
of the things she talks about is that
out by Bristol Township there was a
pizza delivery car that had just kind of
been stolen and has just been ticketed
like multiple times because it was there
but the driver had gone missing the car
was never reported stolen because for
the pizza places they buy the cars used
and it's easier to just let him be a
lost cause than it is to go through all
the paperwork and all that kind of stuff
but this basically gives at least
Commissioner Gordon a tip a direction to
go on at least go investigate that
because the missing person in the entire
situation matches the mo of the Joker
almost down to a T and so of course
Commissioner Gordon goes on his
investigation and at the same time
you've got Batman doing his
investigation where the two of them have
a kind of conversation commissioner
Jordan actually lies and says he's at
the morgue Batman says we'll all be
there soon but ultimately commissioner
Gordon's investigation where he tells
Batman don't worry about it man it's
cool you focused on your case
everything's solid the truth about this
is he's heading to Wayne Manor because
all the clues that he's pieced together
indicate this is where the Joker is and
this is where the Joker's keeping the
Twins and this is where things get nuts
and so that's when you switch over to
the Joker who again is going off on this
kind of maddening bit of a tiring right
the Joker says you don't know anything
but joy do you children besides fear joy
and fear and the Joker says little ones
they're all that matter you lose one and
you'll go crazy you lose both can you
and should you even imagine life without
those anchors of course not you'll go
absolutely mad and so again with Batman
continuing on his investigation he
basically meets with what would be
Harvey Bullock under a normal
circumstance which is to say a detective
in the Gotham City Police Department it
looks like Harvey Bullock still is but
he's kind of a shell of his former
yourself instead of the being the more
grizzled and experienced detective this
guy's just a drunk right like his life
is an absolute mess not only that that
Batman picking up the clues about the
pizza delivery car that Renee Montoya
says the Joker had shown up there one
day and offered everybody a piece of
pizza and then of course because it's
the Joker offering anybody anything
basically everybody said no except for
the new guy right like literally Ricky
this new guy who was working the door
and had no no idea what the Joker was
about and didn't really know to say no
and so of course this pizza had the
Joker toxin in it but what this does is
it tells Batman a couple things one yes
the Joker is the the whole person behind
the stealing of the pizza delivery car
and that two this shows us that Batman
realizes when it comes to the Joker
toxin there that he's never developed a
cure for it this Batman is not nearly as
intelligent or capable as the Batman
that we know from the main DC Universe
because that Bruce Wayne basically
created a toxin for the Joker serum long
ago it was one of the first things he
did when he realized that joker was just
running around with the Toxin and
spraying it on people or exposing it to
people and they would literally just
laugh to death this guy Ricky is just
sitting here laughing his ass off
exposed to the toxin that man does the
only thing he can which is to help this
guy finish with all his living to put
him out of his misery that's the only
thing that he can do and so of course
contacting Oracle Oracle basically
spills the beans and talks to him about
like the pizza delivery car and all that
kind of stuff and she's like Jim Gordon
already has this information and that's
when Batman realizes Jim Gordon has gone
to Wayne Manor to find the joker now now
this point this is when stuff gets so
cool because you have Jim Gordon you
switch over to his character he's making
his way through Wayne Manor he
ultimately catches up to the Joker and
once he enters into the Rune the Joker's
standing there with these two guns
pointed at this kid Jim Gordon
immediately pulls the trigger only for
us to find out it's not the Joker it's
the little girl and she's been put on a
chair and taped to it and dressed to
look like the Joker Jim Gordon took this
girl out not realizing it right and so
of course he runs up there trying to
save her the Joker comes up behind him
slices his throat on the spot dude I
told you guys this story is amazing
right this Joker's story is nuts it's
the greatest Joker story that's ever
been written which makes sense because
it was written by Brian azarello who
wrote The Joker if you guys never read
that story we need to cover it because
it's the second greatest story about The
Joker of all time I might call it that
the second best Joker story ever
I don't know if anybody would watch that
but it is really really good right but
this guy knows how to write the Joker is
the biggest point that I'm making here
but Jim Gordon's dead man like this I
mean he's dying he's not necessarily
dead but basically like Batman rushes to
Wayne Manor as fast as he can possibly
get there and while this is happening
he's met with a broadcast from The Joker
who literally starts showing like Jim
Gordon basically bleeding out and dying
you know choking on his own blood the
little girl who was shot by Jim and this
and like her little brother who's just
there right who's like just watching the
whole thing unfold and so Batman busts
into Wayne Manor and just screams like
what have you done this time and refers
to the joker as Martha because in this
universe Bruce Wayne is dead so here's
how this happened right that I told you
guys the ending to this is crazy and
it's the greatest twist ever for a
Batman comic so here's what happened
right here's here's how this whole thing
unfolded right so what happened is Joe
Chill right just like always goes after
the Wayne family the difference here is
that Thomas attacked him and in the
fight between Thomas and Joe Chill Bruce
Wayne was shot and killed so Bruce is
dead this led to Thomas Wayne going on a
kind of personal Vengeance now to a
degree because of the fact that Martha
was struggling so badly to handle the
entire situation and even when the cops
showed up on the scene and there's like
there's only so much that we can do here
they couldn't find Joe Chill right
they're like we have no clues or
anything like that it filled Thomas
Wayne with rage and it filled Martha
Wayne with grief to the point that like
she's not doing very well with like
therapy she's just grieving she's
depressed trust right she's almost just
kind of in a catatonic State just sort
of sitting there and just kind of
staring out and just she's not really
herself but then it kind of occurs to
Thomas Wayne like what if I took care of
it right what if I'm the one who was
able to to get this sorted out so we
literally paged some random guy to give
him the location of Joe Chill and then
he initially goes after Joe chill with a
needle in order to kill him but instead
he beats him to death he literally beats
Joe Chill to death with his bare hands
it was the first time Batman or really
Thomas Wayne is Batman ever killed
anybody and then once he gets back to
Wayne Manor and he meets with Martha he
tells her like you know it's okay I took
care of it the guy's dead and Martha
spins around and says yeah I understand
now Thomas I'm finally smiling right
it's like it's like uh it's like The
Dark Knight right it's like Heath
Ledger's Batman right now I see the
funny side now I'm always smiling right
so literally Martha went insane because
of the death of Bruce Wayne and she
became the Joker right and so literally
like Bruce Wayne ultimately had her
committed but there was no holding her
back eventually she found a way to
escape and kind of because her Insanity
was rooted in the death of Bruce that's
how she lives her life always going
after kids she's not the Joker that we
know who just goes after anybody and
kind of doing this dance between himself
and Batman and that kind of thing like
it's a cat and mouse almost kind of a
romantic relationship between the two
right one that's predicated on just just
death and destruction and heinousness
and all that kind of stuff but the but
Martha is just outright insane and
almost kind of reliving her past trauma
over and over and over again and so
ultimately what ends up happening here
is that as her and Thomas are fighting
one another he finally catches up to her
and almost has this moment where he he
starts to bring her back right he starts
to bring her back as normal because she
keeps spouting all these things like For
Old Times Sake and all that kind of
stuff so what it looks like is she
hasn't been Joker for all that long it's
not like the Joker in the main DC
Universe where he's been that way for
years potentially even decades or if you
read Scott Snyder is Batman new 52 that
he's he's literally The Pale Man who's
been around for hundreds of years
operating as the Joker I know it's crazy
it's an amazing story we'll have a link
to it down in the description because
the the oh my God Batman in game was
just a great story by Scott Snyder but
the thing here is that as he forces her
to confront this right then he literally
says okay like back to old time's sake
what if I told you that things could
have been different what if I told you
that we were in Crime Alley and there's
two gunshots that get fired and then two
bodies fall over and a boy is left
crying what if I told you it could have
just been us who died right what if I
told you that I could change things so
that it was us who died and our son
lived would you not be okay with giving
your life for our son and the response
of Martha is promise me if you can
change things that you will right
promise me Thomas you can you can set
things back to normal and so ultimately
it's a cool moment because he's able to
kind of reel her back to becoming normal
again and so then she simply says then
tell me about Bruce what does he do
after we're dead because remember Barry
Allen told Thomas everything about the
Bruce Wayne from the main DC Universe
and so what kind of gave Thomas hope
because it's like my son lives I mean
sure he becomes a vigilante and he
betrays the Justice League a few times
and you know he's got infinite prep time
under any circumstance but still right
like at least he lives and he he finds a
way to avenge our deaths in the best way
that he can possibly do but when this
when this situation is spilled to Martha
where she asked the question like when
literally Thomas says he follows his
Father's Footsteps and she asks he
becomes a doctor the response of Batman
is no and that's when she realizes he
becomes like you are like he becomes
what you are but in a different universe
and she snaps back to being your joke
herself there's no way to bring her back
there's no way to fix her right there's
no way to get her back to being sane but
as she takes off running she ends up
basically slipping down into a hole to
what would have normally been the bat
cave had it been discovered by Thomas
Wayne but falling down into this giant
hole in the middle of the ground she
ultimately just crashes onto the ground
below and breaks your neck in the
process and that's the end of Martha
Wayne that's the story of her that's
literally where the story ends it just
kind of ends all of a sudden but I told
you guys it's the greatest Joker story
ever told it's phenomenal it's got like
the best twist ever so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end hopefully we see this in the
flashpoint film thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace